what I'm going to do now is ask the
deputy partum to pass this verdict down
starting with journal I juror number one
does that verdict represent your true an
individual verdict okay
juror number two does that verdict
represent your true an individual
verdict juror number three is that brick
verdict juror number four does that
verdict represent your true an
individual verdict juror number five
does that verdict represent your true an
individual verdict juror number six does
that verdict represent your true an
individual verdict
juror number seven does at Burak
represent you to an individual verdict
juror number eight does that verdict
juror number nine does that verdict
represent sure to an individual verdict
sure enough ten does that verdict
represent you to an individual verdict
juror number eleven does that Burak
in juror number 12
does that verdict represent your to an
individual verdict Phil never man
coughing man lurk will you please
publish the verdict verdict of Puri
meeting title of court and cause we the
jury in the body find the defendant Hans
Reiser guilty of a murder a violation of
section 187 Farah a of the Penal Code of
California in that honor about September
3rd 2006 in the county of Alameda state
of California said defendant did
unlawfully and with malice Africa murder
Nina Reiser a human being as charged in
information with the jury fix the degree
of the above offense as murder of the
first degree
death April 28 2008 foreperson red 87
Bayesian German is that your verdict
okay you may record the group the
parking is recorded your honor thank you
we have mr. Reiser then taking back
upstairs
alright ladies and gents I indicated to
you first of all before I indicate
anything to you I want to thank you it's
beyond words the duty that you've
performed for Allen County way beyond
the call of duty way beyond my time
estimate you were here on time you were
punctual you were diligent you took
plenty of notes you were serious about
the task and you stayed engaged in the
entire proceeding and on behalf of Amida
County in the Superior Court I can't
tell you how grateful we are for your
service as I indicated to you you are
now free to discuss the case with
anybody or allow anybody to discuss the
case with you if you want them to again
as I indicated to you it has to be with
your approval at a time that you doing
reasonable also as I indicated to the
lawyers may want to talk to you about
the case mr. Dubois mr. Tamura may want
to talk to you if you want to talk to
them up on the 6th floor you can mr.
hora will go up there also is that what
you're going to do okay so if you want
to go back to the jury deliberation room
the lawyers will be up there to discuss
things with you afterwards if you'd like
to come down and talk to me you can
learn happy I'm here until 5:00 so feel
free to come back down here because I
indicated also to you there all these
letters that were presented to me by the
people from 48 hours we'll make these
available to you you're not bound by
anything in here but they no one will
talk to you they may not one important
thing I do have to tell you about is to
90 days from today you cannot accept any
payment for anything about any payment
or promised
you